da quando sono tornato in italia come ho
messo il piede fuori dall'aereo è già un
freddo cane se fa un freddo cane in
italia non so perché il giappone fa un
caldo veste in italia con freddo cane
stamattina mi sono alzato dal letto che
c'è un freddo borgo quindi sono ancora
in pigiama toe con la coperta e non vi
dovete rompere le palle me ne frega la
segat quattro vie di iscritti tanto li
ho già fatti quindi non c'è bisogno che
devo avere buona presenza chi se ne
fotte tanto ce li ho già e 4 mian e
[ __ ] era più di ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono fa vj oggi
siamo in un video un po particolare
questo che l'uomo ha fatto di smi mi
vorrete ultimamente aveva fatto vedere
come era lui prima di youtube come era
lui nel web prima di youtube mi piace un
sacco lo faccio anche io ma faringei
vasca coperta e howard cosa fa un
barbaro incredibile 18 settembre mi 17
romano ha fatto felice obiettivi ci
aspetta aspetta aspetta stato fatto
ancora ritorno su slam il ritorno sul
renderman dopo anni che non lo faceva
che ti 9 settembre alle 17 ho fatto io
vi odio fugiendo prima vide un mese fa
quando l'ho fatto mese fa il 31 agosto
invece 7 squid renderman quindi
significa che ho due video di ripicca
quindi posso copia vi è ancora un altro
vediamo come rafa vj prima di entrare su
youtube
tenetevi forte perché io ero veramente
un bimbominkia sembra un po di bruch da
uno dei miei heather su guanti io ho
passato un periodo purtroppo dove andavo
e stavo su yahoo
non è mio però faceva troppo ridere
problema online i due solo per hacker
solo per hacker
eccolo qua eccoci qua
ride mi chiamo ride e posso già chiesta
pagina sala stuprata da tutti quelli che
vedranno questo video
andrò a vedere cosa ho scritto ma tanto
lo faccio già io la prima domanda sulle
lance meglio playstation 3 o xbox 360
sicuramente fatto bene a chiedere perché
sono massimi esperti ste robe ragazzi a
settembre a prendermi la playstation 3
xbox 360 però io mi avvicino dpa la
playstation 3 perché essa ha un
bellissimo essa parla come mangi cioè
che non mangi perchè 6 mag mi stai zitto
ha un bellissimo gioco che desideravo da
tempo e che le giostre 60 non sa ovvero
metà gli assoli 3 voi cosa fareste
un mio amico hai visto poi ha detto che
l'xbox 360 una grafica migliore l'ho
messa come migliore risposta e poi ho
comprato la ps3 però non c'entra la sega
ciao a tutti avevano andare a fare
recentemente ordinato su internet degli
occhiali in 3d a ragazzi la cosa che fa
veramente più ridere di tutto questo io
ho ordinato negli occhiali 3d da possono
io posso dire queste cose ne un video
perché rimangono s'intende per sempre
vedrete di disney channel faceva andate
in onda il film diana montane in 3d e
per vederlo in 3d su tre giorni tutto
per mandare una mail disney channel con
il tuo indirizzo così disney channel di
biava gli occhiali 3d di hannah montana
per vedere film di hannah montana bene
uomini gli altri tempi scrivete una
barzelletta la migliore per la scelta la
miglior risposta marancia un cazzo da
fare quando loro piccolo nove anni fa
avevo 13 anni ma vai a [ __ ] porca
vacca magari qualcosa di divertente
uscito visto che quest'anno l'ho messa a
cinque stelle giudice o maniaco allora
ha violentato la madre la sorella minore
la sorella maggiore cosa ha da dire a
sua discolpa e il maniaco volevo farmi
una famiglia
perché ho scelto questa è solo due
domande buona dice perché la lingua blu
e l'altra perché ho fatto un principe
azzurro davanti programmi torrent
tuttora bravo che scarica cose ciao a
tutti un programmone ieri mi sono
sporcato le mani di inchiostro quindi se
i figli sono andate in bagno e
accendendo la luce ha scelto macchiato
il muro con un puntino nero inchiostro
ho provato a toglierlo con l'acqua da
muro ma si espande solo avete qualche
soluzione
ragazzi io questa ve la devo spiegare li
prego non fa troppo ridere aveva un
pennarello indelebile e lo so masticando
proprio stop masticando perché loro
deficiente ma stiamo i pennarelli loro
secchia tofino ad accorgermi che loro 8
celentano si chiama loro quindi
l'inchiostro riuscito tutto e mi ha
sporcato dove tutti i denti il caso di
quindi appena io ho guardato le mie mani
grano sporche d'inchiostro e anche i
denti sporchi di grasso tutto compreso
ho lanciato la coperta perché sto con la
coperta che i tempi sono corso in bagno
ho acceso la luce con la mano sporca
d'inchiostro ovviamente pigiare il tasto
dell'accensione della luce l'ho mancato
e ho colpito il muro quindi era lasciato
un pallino nero di inchiostro sul modo
alla fine ho usato il solvente per le
unghie quello di mia madre per toglierlo
dal muro problema che si è tolta anche
la vernice quindi il muro era tipo blu
poi ho passato un solvente è diventato
il muro blu con la macchia bianca perché
non c'era più il blu perché ho tolto
anche la vernice poi visto che non
riuscivo più a risolvere ho cambiato
casa e sono venuto ad abitare a milano o
tutti i pokémon esistenti fino ad oggi
su pokemon platino li regalo o tutti i
pochi un esistenti fino ad oggi a
partire da chico rita finire con un po
leon anche tutti i leggendari né chi è
con te i suoi kun e tutti quelli nuovi
fan che di aglio all'odio o tutti al 100
e tutti shiny posso regalarvi tutto
quello che volete anche benefattore
perché lo faccio non lo so dato che lì o
infiniti mi sento di dargli anche agli
altri
ed è così che si completa la [ __ ] così
vediamo se la figlia è arrivata ei baby
eccola le ultra kiss
bella è bella spero sia al suo nome sono
timida e vecchio volto o rimorchiato la
[ __ ]
chiamate non hanno spendermi chiacchiere
inutili bene meno chiacchiere e più
fatti seri e ebay pivot era come si
rimorchia giusto grande solo scherzando
qui abbiamo rimarcato da belle ragazze
sacco di pokémon potete vedere il mio
pickers ragazzi aiutatemi un problema ne
sono questi i problemi della vita ho
installato prototype con tanto di
parentesi quadre apre il gioco facciamo
una partita mica di creare una sorta di
salvataggio dell'ok ma mi dice
impossibile salvare i dati in pratica
non mi fa salvare non posso nemmeno
iniziare il gioco faccina triste gioco
originale
aspetto solo di gioco originale problema
con utorrent di fa vj mentre scarico
lascio il pc acceso gioco originale
mentre scarico gioco originale originale
se originale vai dove l'hai acquistato
classificazione del referente una stella
meraviglioso meraviglioso questa roba da
otto anni fa un giornalista di the sims
lentezza barratt chissà perché tutti sti
problemi quei giochi originali problema
fallout 3 ragazzi un problema ne ho
messo il crack di palla out 3 gioco
originale ragazzi ho messo su youtube
questo video l'ho messo da poco ho
notato che sta salendo bene le
visualizzazioni con bene di
visualizzazioni intendo che ne avevo
fatte tipo 50 o forse cento
forse c'è potete dargli 5 stelle
lasciare un commento per favore 5 stelle
perché ai tempi su youtube si mettevano
le stelle c'è invece non c'era mi piace
c'erano metti 5 stelle come se adesso
alla fine del video dice sì vi è
piaciuto lasciati 5 stelle se
rientravano dei più visti sarà anche
merito vostro
grazie mille a chi contribuirà ecco come
l'aifa televi un pezzo di merda problema
a stelle di votazione gli eau 5
bellissimo ragazzi che ho messo youtube
sono sparite le stelle per votare un
video ora c'è solo il pollice in su e
del pollice in giù ma non ci sono più le
stelle è normale che samsung bug il mio
poi per i prossimi 10 anni zio non ci
saranno più le stelle mi dispiace che
erano più belle le stelle ragazzi mi
risolvete questa equazione spiegandomi
basso per basso perché non l'ho capita
bravo che ti fai fare i compiti su yahoo
answers nicchia ragazzi per noi andremo
avanti ora troppo avanti ragazzi siamo
arrivati all'ultima cerca di leggere
questa assenza ridere ci provo sento la
mia ragazza più distaccata e normale
ciao ragazzi non uso spesso ancora ma
questa volta ho bisogno di qualche
parere vostro spero possiate darmi una
mano
sembravi ragazza da circa sette mesi
siamo molto legati non so scrivere
quanto perché è difficile da spiegare
basti sapere che non siamo comunque come
2 classe s per cosa mi preoccupa che
recentemente gli ultimi giorni sento la
mia ragazza p distaccata nel senso che
ci scambiamo messaggi più fredda
sbrigativa meno coccolosa del solito
per farla breve avesse le sue cose lo
capirei ci sono questi momenti di
depressione già successo ma il fatto che
non è nel periodo
la cosa più strana è che non mi sembra
di aver fatto qualcosa di strano in
genere mi accorgo subito premetto che la
nostra è come era una relazione a
distanza incontri genitori nelle di
firenze ma comunque grazie al treno a
vederci almeno ultime due settimane
periodo scolastico
quindi noi mandiamo secoli senza averci
anche perché non resistere con questo
hanno preoccupato e da qualche giorno
che così anche per annego lei non riesco
a trovare la soluzione
lei dice che era la stanchezza perché
dormiva poco due giorni vostro parere
così come stare malissimo anche se non
lo do a vedere bene anche legge cazzola
risposto alla lascia perdere basta bass
vi prego questo è l'apice della
stronzata da ticket service avere la
testa tipo 20.038 poi per fare quest
ultima domanda sono passati quattro anni
sette anni fa erano le altre domande per
tre anni non ho scritto niente al corso
trovato il profilo di netlog nori the
best maschio 24 anni ma dove in cerca di
relazione situazioni limite singolo rack
sa perché foto della mia vita hannah
montana e dragon ball e basta cioè da un
connubio tra hannah montana e dragon
ball che c'azzecca di brutto sono
appassionato di dragon ball e secondo me
anche di hannah montana mentre aprire
che possiamo concludere che questo video
molto triste mio essere fa vj prima di
essere famiglie spero che questo video
vi sia piaciuto a meno stato molto
triste ripercorre tutte le cagate che
che ho fatto però cose dice mi piace e
mi piace anche anzi lasciato cinque
stelle anche il religioso egiziane sono
questi dischi mettevi e noi ci vediamo
alla prossima vita da ragazzi
[Musica]